Mới công bó bộ trường anh nguồn điểm Mi Cristinao em cho rằng,
Mà phát hiện những số hiệu cho thấy một số tiến bị cá nhân của mình,
bị cai phần mềm theo sỏi khi đầm nhận cưng vị lãnh gạo bộ.
Mà cho biết có chuyên gia công nghệ trong đó có sự hỗ trợ từ tìm phủ elm mơ,
đã giúp kiểm tra và phát hiện các phần mềm,
như vẫn trên địt hoại và máy tính sách tay.
Theo bạn, nó em, bánh đề đã được chuyển cho các lực sự để làm xa ó và đánh xá tính pháp li của các hoạt động liên quan.
Bà cũng đề cập phía phát hiện một cơ sở lưu trữ tại lựa mặt chưa được biết đến trong khôn viên cơ quan,
chưa rằng cần giả só thần diện các quy trình anh nguyện bầu.
Tuy nhiên, nếu vụ trường thông công bộ bằng trực cụ thề,
cho các cáu bộ về nhà nước ngầm hay hỏa đậm gió tham.
Khi đường đến nghị bình luật, bó anh nguyện nguyện mi trở biết sẽ không được ra phát hôn bộ xong,
trong khi giới quan xanh nhận định,
có tuy môn này của thế làm xa tăng chinh luận về bộ máy hàng chính và anh nguyện bộ tạm đi.